Bitte schön.
Okay. Guten Tag.
Ja, schon einen guten Tag.
AK ist mein Name.
Ich bin Momentan der Dishabender.
Ja, AK ist mein Name.
Ich bin für Sie da.
Kurz zum Ablauf.
Zuerst werde ich Ihre persönliche Daten nachfragen.
Dann Ihre Bescheiden.
Und am Ende einige Informationen über Ihre Familie.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Sind Sie damit einfach verstanden?
Ja, das klingt gut. Ja.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Alina Müller.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamenbuch stabilen?
M-U-Doppel-L-G-R.
Okay.
Einer der häufigsten Namen in Deutschland. Müller.
Ja.
Okay, dann. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1., 3., 86.
Wie groß sind Sie?
M-U-Doppel-L-G-R.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie?
62 kg. 62,5 kg.
Okay, Frau Müller. Danke für die Formation.
Also, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was haben Sie bescheiden?
Ja, ich habe seit vier Tagen so unglaublich starke Kopf- und Nattenschmerzen.
Ich kann mich eigentlich kaum rühren.
Und die Schmerzen werden nicht besser.
Die werden immer schlimmer.
Und das strahlt tatsächlich so vom Nacken aus in den linken Arm rein.
Und eben auch in den Kopf hoch.
Und es sind wirklich sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe schon drei Ibuprofen genommen.
Aber das hilft immer nur so ein ganz bisschen.
Und ich habe da mal probiert,
so ein Wärmekissen in den Nacken zu legen.
Das hilft auch ein wenig, aber nicht wirklich grundlegend.
Und mir ist jetzt eigentlich richtig schlecht und ich kann nachts nicht schlafen.
Und ja, ich mag auch im Augenblick gar nichts essen.
Okay, ich verstehe, Frau Müller.
Also, wo genau sind diese Schmerzen im Kopf?
Am hinten oder am ganzen Kopf?
Ja, ich würde sagen, die strahlen so vom Nacken aus hoch.
Wie so eine Mütze.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzverwaltung 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht sehr stark ist.
Aber die sind im Augenblick wirklich bestimmt bei 7.
Das sind wirklich sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Ist ihnen auch übel oder haben sie schon erbrechen?
Nein, übergeben musste ich mich nicht.
Aber übel ist mir wirklich, ja, ich fühle mich richtig schlecht.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Empfindlichkeit gegen Licht bemerkt zum Beispiel?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Nein.
Erleben Sie so zu beschwerden, was heißt das mal in Ihrem Leben oder vorher hatten Sie schon?
Ich habe das wirklich noch nie gehabt und das ist wirklich, also ganz, ja, ganz überraschend.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch gekommen, weil das seit Tagen eben überhaupt nicht besser wird.
Ich kenne so etwas gar nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen. Ich habe aber keine Temperatur.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche andere Beschwerden, Frau Müller?
Haben Sie noch etwas Ungewöhnliches?
Nein, sonst ist mir eigentlich nicht besonderes aufgefallen.
Ja, aber diese Schmerzen, die machen mich wirklich fertig.
Ja, Frau Müller, ich kann Ihnen ein Schmerz mitgeben, wenn Sie brauchen,
aber wenn Sie nur etwas aushalten.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt ja schon seit ein paar Tagen.
Jetzt kommt auf eine halbe Stunde auch nicht mehr.
Wenn Sie mir nachher...
Das kann man gerade überhaupt nichts hören.
Also nichts verstehen.
Was sagen Sie?
Ich konnte das gerade, das letzte überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Das letzte, was ich verstanden habe war, ob ich ein Schmerz mitteln will.
Ich habe gesagt, nein, danke. Ich halte es noch aus.
Lass mich mein Video schliessen.
Vielleicht habe ich das besser.
Okay.
Keine Schilligung, aber vielleicht...
Ja, jetzt ist das Haus besser.
Ja, eindeutig.
Ja, okay.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sie sind wirklich brennend, ich würde sagen.
Und im Kopf stand vielleicht eher noch so drückend.
Aber brennend ist wohl beschrat, ist wohl ganz gut.
Frau Müller, haben Sie Nackensteichigkeit bemerkt?
Ich meine zum Beispiel können Sie Ihren Kopf auf Brustbein?
Ja, ich habe das nicht.
Das haben wir da nichts mehr.
Frau Müller, hört es Sie nicht?
Ja, jetzt kann ich wieder etwas hören.
Ja, okay.
Das Verb fehlt ja noch.
Ich kann meinen Kopf nicht gut drehen, weil Bewegung tut es noch mehr weh.
Okay.
Deswegen schon ich das schon, versuch das irgendwie, es wenig zu bewegen.
Ich verstehe Frau Müller, haben Sie nach Schweißausbrüche oder Stütze Brust?
Nee, sowas habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe halt schlecht schlafen, weil ich nicht richtig liegen kann.
Und weil ich halt so Schmerzen habe.
Ja.
Hallo?
Hallo, habe ich nicht gehört?
Ja, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Okay.
Und die Appetit, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass die Appetit ist auch nicht gut.
Ja, weil mir so übel ist.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nee.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nee, normalerweise nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Frau Müller, auch gegen Corona?
Ja, ja, doch mein Hausarzt ist da eigentlich sehr gründlich.
Gründlich und Corona habe ich natürlich mich darum gekümmert,
damit ich auch wieder zur Arbeit gehen kann.
Ja, das ist sehr schön.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nie.
Also Frau Müller, ja, sind Sie sexuell aktiv?
Noch mal bitte.
Sind Sie sexuell aktiv?
Haben Sie einen Partner?
Ja, ich lebe mit meinen Freunden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme bei Michel Svelker?
Nein.
Ist Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Ja.
Ich nehme die Pille, insofern ist das kein Grund.
Okay, dann.
Es ist unmöglich, dass Sie momentan schon angerufen sind.
Okay.
Ja, das kann ich auch.
Also Frau Müller, leiden Sie an Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich so gar nichts.
Ich bin eigentlich ein ganz gesunder Mensch.
Das Einzige, ich habe mir meinen Arm gebrochen vor 12 Jahren,
aber sonst bin ich immer kerngesund gewesen.
Von 12 Jahren an gebrochen.
Und hat es eine Operation dafür?
Das ist operiert worden.
Ja, das ist ein Operation.
Das ist eine Operation.
Hat es eine Operation dafür?
Das ist operiert worden.
Ja, da ist eine Platte reingekommen.
Und nachher auch wieder raus.
Aber das ist alles gut verlaufen.
Ah, okay.
Das ist schön.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich ein?
Gelegentlich habe ich jetzt die Büro genommen.
Gegen die Kopfschmerzen.
Aber regelmäßig nehme ich nur meine Pille ein.
Das ist ja, Y, A, Z.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und die Büro, keine welche Dosis?
Ich meine, das wäre ein 600er gewesen.
Sind bei Ihnen welche Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich so eine Pollenallergie.
Im Frühling, wenn die Pollen fliegen,
dann bekomme ich Schnupfen und die Augen trennen.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, also wenig, sage ich mal.
Ich habe wenig geraucht.
Inzwischen rauche ich gar nicht mehr.
Aber ich habe so 10 Jahre lang,
habe ich ein Päckchen pro Woche ungefähr geraucht.
Also wirklich immer nur so, als Genussraucher.
Nicht viel.
Okay.
Ja.
Kennen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das trinke ich schon gelegentlich so.
Das, was ich abends mal gelassen war,
zwei bis dreimal in einer Woche.
Okay.
Und Frau Müller, bitte,
sagen Sie nicht,
dass das nur eine routine Frage ist,
nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, das meine ich.
Also, wie ist Ihr Familienstand für Frau Müller?
Ich bin ledig.
Ich lebe mit meinem Freund zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, Kinder haben wir nicht.
Was machen Sie bei Refleech?
Ich arbeite im Büro, im öffentlichen Dienst.
Also viel Schreibarbeit und Schreibdestätigkeit.
Büroarbeit, ja?
Genau.
Okay.
Frau Müller, gibt es wichtige Krankheiten
in Ihren nahen Verwandtschaften?
Ich meine hier Ihre Eltern, Ihre Geschwister.
Ich habe nicht, mein Vater hatte vor zwei Jahren.
Nein, so etwas,
mein Vater hatte jetzt vor zwei Jahren Herzenschaft
und das ist aber gut abgefangen worden.
Der hat einen Stand bekommen und seitdem geht es dem eigentlich gut.
Das ist sehr schön.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Die Mutter, die ist eigentlich gesund.
Die hatte nur vor 15 Jahren mal eine Knie-OP,
aber sonst geht es der gut.
Also keine chronischen Krankheiten.
Wir sind eine gesunde Familie.
Ja, das voll.
Also, ja.
Okay, dann Frau Müller.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen von meiner Seite schon gestellt.
Jetzt werde ich Sie über weitere Schritte informieren.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen?
Ja, wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Was kann die Ursache sein?
Was kann man dagegen tun?
Ich muss irgendwann wieder arbeiten.
Mit diesem Dröhnenkopf kann ich ja nicht zu Arbeit gehen.
Ich kann nicht Auto fahren und gar nichts.
Und fühle mich also wirklich eingeschränkt.
Ja, Frau Müller, unsere Untersuchungen sind noch nicht zu Ende.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Aber nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von
der Hin-Haut-Entschuldung aus.
Okay.
Ja, aber wie ich schon gesagt habe, das ist jetzt nur eine Verdacht.
Aber ist das nicht gefährlich?
Das könnte gefährlich sein,
aber andererseits ist das auch gut behandelbar.
Aber Sie sollen hier im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Nach Deinem Untersuchungen werden wir wieder genauer sprechen.
Ja, okay.
Okay, dann, Frau Müller, wiedersehen.
Ja, bis später.
Okay.
So, gibt es denn jetzt noch Fragen?
Fragen von anderer Seite.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob es irgendwelche Auflöser gibt
für diese Schmerzen?
Also, jetzt, ein Auslöser gab es nicht.
Das Einzige, eben bei Bewegung, wurden die schlechter.
Ich kann mich also nicht bewegen.
Und deswegen bewege ich mich halt nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten
oder langsam angefangen?
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Ja, die haben leicht angefangen und sind immer schlimmer geworden,
würde ich sagen.
Wie viele Jahre arbeiten Sie am Tisch?
Ich meine Officearbeit.
Oh, ja, schon von Anfang an, also seit ich meine Lehre abgeschlossen habe.
Also seit, ja, alt bin ich 36, seit fast 20 Jahren.
Gut, Dr. Moab, jetzt sind Sie bereit für das Oberarztgespräch?
Ich brauche ein paar Minuten davor.
Alles gut, ja, alles gut. Ich trinke es so lange.
Haben Sie irgendein Tapreizgefühl oder Kribbel im linken Arm?
Oder eine Körper-Pilot?
Nein, nein, ne, hab ich nicht. Zum Glück.
Super, mir denn nacken schon wirklich viel.
Ich bin ein super Hypochondri.
Ich kriege immer alles, was ich euch erzähle.
Ich kriege auch tatsächlich.
Boah, ruhig war.
Muss ich mir gut überlegen, welchen Fall ich raussoh,
was ich auf keinen Fall habe.
Haben Sie Rückenschmerzen auf?
Rückenschmerzen?
Ja.
Nein, im Augenblick nicht.
Aber ich bin jetzt schon hochberuhigt,
weil ich mir auch mitgekommen habe,
dass ich vielleicht eine Hirnhaut entzündung hätte.
Da habe ich ja bisher nichts Gutes von gehört.
Insofern bin ich etwas genervt.
Mal gucken.
Vielleicht ja Bandscheibenverfahren.
Vielleicht, das wäre auch nicht viel besser, oder?
Ja.
Nehmen wir Pesto oder Cola Reis.
Also können wir?
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag Frau Beetz.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patience vorstellen.
Aber natürlich.
Frau Alina Müller, 36-jährige Patientin.
1,67 m groß und 62 kg schwer.
Ich habe eine neue Patience vorgestellt.
Aber natürlich.
Frau Alina Müller, 36-jährige Patientin.
Ich weiß nicht wer.
Frau Müller beschwert sich
über seit 4 Tagen
Bestehende,
Brennhante,
Zurückende,
Schmerzen im Kopf
und Nakenbereich.
Die Schmerzen
haben plötzlich angefangen
und im Lauferwärtszeit
die Maschilima geworden.
Also, ja.
Ja, die Schmerzen strahlen in den linken Arm aus.
In den linken Arm, ja.
Frau Müller hat dagegen über Profen eingenommen und warme Kissen versucht, aber das hat sie nicht ganz geholfen.
Ja, das hat ihr nicht ganz geholfen.
Die Intensität der Schmerzen bewertet Frau Müller als sieben auf eine Schmerzskala.
Sie leidet auch an nausea.
Lymphenfindlichkeit und Fieber wurden verneint.
Sie lebt mit Bewegung des Kopfes verschlechtert.
Verlechtert?
Ja, und übrigens meldet sie über Insomni wegen des Schmerzes.
Ja, sie beschreibt Insomni.
Sie erlebt das erste Mal.
Zum ersten Mal, ja.
Also, neuer Geschichte. Was macht sie denn beruflich?
Ja, sie ist eine Büroarbeiterin.
Okay.
Man muss wahrscheinlich viel Computerarbeit machen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufregig.
Sie hat keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sie nimmt an Medikamente, nimmt sie Pille und bei Bedarf über Profen 600 mg.
Bei der Patientin erfolgt eine osteosyntöse Antebrakymobarm und dann ja, vor 12 Jahren.
Bei ihr ist holleneilegipekant.
Sie reagiert mit Schnupfen und trennende Augen.
Momentan ist sie nicht traurig, aber vorher hat sie für 10 Jahre ein Päckchen pro Woche geraucht.
Sie trinkt 2-3 Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist ledig.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Freund, hat keine Kinder.
Sie ist Büroarbeiterin von Beruf.
Bei der Familienanamnese hat sie angegeben, dass sein Vater,
sein Vater, Miokat infaktus hatte.
Ihr Freund hat ja nicht.
Ist er daran gestorben?
Nein, sie erlebt.
Die beiden Eltern sind noch am Leben.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese.
Was ist jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Diskusprolapsus.
Das sind die Differenzialdiagnosen?
Ja, das können Sie noch sein.
Muskelkrenzle, vielleicht unbesondere.
Ich denke noch an zwei Sachen.
Es kam vorhin die Frage nach Rensibilitätsstörungen in der linken Hand.
Das war das noch Übelkeit und Sehstörungen.
Sie gehen in eine andere Richtung.
Was könnte das sein?
Das könnte auch Migräne sein.
Worstcase, schlimmstenfalls,
muss man auch rechnen.
Das muss man ausschließen.
Das ist das.
Ein anderes?
Ja, noch etwas anderes.
Es ist jetzt hier im Fall als Differenzialdiagnose aufgeführt.
Ich meine,
das ist der wildeste Fall.
Man kann es, wenn es gibt,
in einer anderen Richtung.
Hier war noch ein Tumor geschehen.
Das steht aber auch als allerletztes.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin bei der Untersuchung?
Was untersuchen Sie?
Ja, zuerst würde ich die Patientin
körperlich untersuchen.
Beide körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Zum Beispiel,
die Bolognicki und die Kernlinge sind sehr wichtig.
Natürlich, wie Teilparameter würde ich auch.
Ja, gut.
Und dann vielleicht mal
die Sensibilität von der linken Hand.
Neurologisch untersuchend, meine Sie?
Ja, genau.
Natürlich, neurologisch untersuchend ist auch sehr wichtig.
Ich meine,
die Hinnerven
und Motorik und Sensibilität
sind sehr wichtig.
Was würde man auf alle Fälle machen?
Kopelderflixen?
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein offizieller Teil der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie denn labortechnisch?
Ich würde Bullet abnehmen.
Bullet sind die Entschimmungsparameter.
Dann ist die Lokozidanzahl auch wichtig.
Was machen wir operativ?
Normaalpunkzion würde ich auch durchführen.
Eigentlich nur, wenn der Verdacht auf meinen Gittes sich bestärkt.
Ich weiß nicht,
macht man die Indikation für die Normaalpunkzion,
ist das nicht ziemlich eng.
Was wäre denn die deutlich angenehmere Untersuchung?
Vorher?
Ich würde mich an der Normaal-Suchung vielleicht aufzutreten.
Beziehungsweise?
Ich habe es gerne.
Genau.
Wenn sich da kein Verdacht zeigt,
muss man in den sauren Apfel beißen
und diese Lumbalfunktion machen.
Wenn es jetzt tatsächlich das HWS-Syndrom ist,
was wäre denn Ihre Therapieoption?
Bei HWS-Syndrom-Physiotherapie ist es sehr effektiv.
Wenn es z.B. eine schwere Discos-Prolapsung gibt,
sollen wir das operativ behandeln?
Das wäre dann operativ anzugehen.
Macht man eher Wärme oder eher Kälte drauf?
Noch mal bitte.
Würde man eher mit Wärme oder eher mit Kälte behandeln?
Ja, Wärme, denke ich.
Gott sei Dank.
Der Gedanke an Kälte im Nacken ist grauenvoll.
Medikamentös, was könnte man da machen?
Schmerztabletzen.
Auf alle Fälle, klar.
Ich fühle das jetzt gerade so selber.
Dass die einen total verspannten Nacken und Halsbereich hat.
Ich mache ja selber wirklich schon so.
Muskelrelaxant.
Eine Fähigung, Wärme, Muskelentspannung.
Okay, wir werden schon besser.
Alles klar.
Wunderbar.
Das waren tatsächlich die Sachen.
Wenn es auf Migräne hindeuten würde.
Wo würden Sie dann gucken?
Da gab es noch mal Prüfernachfragen in diesem Fall.
Meinen Sie erst diagnostische Maßnahmen oder therapeutische Maßnahmen?
Nein, eigentlich mehr von der Diagnostik her.
Von der Anamnese her.
Passt das so richtig zur Migräne, was Sie beschrieben hat?
Migräne kann sein, aber Lichtempfindigkeit wurde verneint.
Genau.
Das finde ich auch ein ganz wichtiges Kriterium.
Und auch dieses Kribbeln in der Hand fehlt.
Ich habe das schon mal erzählt.
Ich habe als ganz junge Frau grauenvolle Migräneattacken gehabt.
Das erste Mal, als es aufgetreten ist, habe ich tatsächlich im Krankenhaus gelegen.
Und die haben mich untersucht auf Minigitis.
Weil ich komplett ein Gesichtsheld ausfall hatte.
Und absolutes Kribbeln in der Hand und auch wirklich langanhaltend.
Und ich war gerade zu Beginn der Pubertät.
Die haben mir dann tatsächlich die Lumballfunktion gemacht.
Und dann war es Gott sei Dank ausgeschlossen.
Und dann war es dann auch ein bisschen langanhaltend.
Und damit war dann irgendwo die Diagnose klar, dass das Migräne ist.
Und ich habe da so wie ich die klassische Migräne gehabt, auch mit der vorherigen Aura.
Und diese Gesichtsausfälle sind sowas von dramatisch.
Ist extrem onlanggemengen wirklich.
Und nachher auffällig eben die Lichtempfindlichkeit.
Und Gott sei Dank gibt es so eine Migräneattacke auch nicht über vier Tage.
Ich glaube, da wäre man irgendwie ausgetickt vorher.
Aber tatsächlich sind diese beiden Diagnosen schon verdammt dicht beieinander.
Und die Location der Schmerzen bei Migräne wäre haltseitig.
Meistens vermuten die.
Nein, weiß aber ja.
Wäre praktisch wenn die linke Hand getroffen ist, wäre das rechtzeitig quasi.
Die Gehirnärfte würde wehtun.
Ach so, ihr seht das richtig rum.
Ja, na gut.
Perfekt.
Also ich würde mal sagen, das war eine super Anamnese.
Wie viele haben Sie schon gemacht?
20.
Der Gruppe das erste.
Für mich, für mich in der Gruppe aber total vielleicht 10.
Super, also ich fand Sprache nicht wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Und.
Danke.
Also wirklich überhaupt fast nix.
Das einzige, was mich wirklich ein bisschen irritiert hat.
Was man vielleicht so ein bisschen diskutieren müsste, ist die Geschichte.
Wenn die Patientin nicht ganz so blöd ist, ja,
dann würde die natürlich höchst beunruhigt sein.
Wenn sie ihr von vorderen Rang von der Menigitis Diagnose erzählen.
Ja, da geht ja die Alarmglocken an.
Ja, solange sie das nicht wissen.
Ja, eine gefährliche.
Ich meine zum Beispiel ein Verdacht über Karsinum würde ich das nie sagen,
als Verdacht.
Aber genau das finde ich, das war ja natürlich.
Ja, also das kann ja auch verdammt daneben gehen.
Also so eine Menigitis kann ja auch bleiben, die Schäden hinterlassen.
Und ja, ja.
Wir ich jetzt vorsichtig und.
Aber eigentlich haben Sie ja, Vorfels haben Sie ja gesagt,
ja, kann man erst sagen, wenn wir die Untersuchung abnehmen,
kann man erst sagen, wenn wir die Untersuchung abgeschlossen haben,
damit wäre es ja gut gewesen.
Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, das war eine absolute perfekte Vorstellung.
Und ich glaube, Sie können wirklich sehr, sehr gelassen in Ihre Prüfung reingehen.
Vielen Dank, das ist sehr nett von Ihnen.
Ja, und tatsächlich, das war jetzt ein bisschen nervig mit der,
mit der akustischen Übermittlung, dass das nicht so ganz schlüssig gelaufen ist.
Und ist natürlich netter, wenn man sich angucken kann.
Aber so war es ja wenigstens erträglich und machbar.
Und wir haben, glaube ich, nur einige Aussetzer mitten drin gehabt.
Gut, heute ist schon, ja, möchte noch irgendjemand was dazu sagen,
von den Kollegen, Kolleginnen.
Okay, keiner. Ja, gut.
Dann können wir.